well you know because of Virginia Beach
is primarily this kind of skate and surf
culture it's um a lot of the things that
surround the people there are valued
according to the brands I guess and so
from a very early age I from a very
early age I was noticing how branding
and logos and images on objects created
or rather increase the perceived value
of those objects and so you know
certainly while while I grew up at the
beach and and and skateboarding I was
never really good at any of those
activities but what I really um I guess
was good at to some extent was kind of
emulating those graphics and and logos
because I couldn't afford the cool brand
so I would you know make my own shirts
and paint on my own skateboards and
those objects in turn almost ironically
became valued by other people and so
there's a I started to understand how
that worked and I wanted to assume that
power and that's what kind of led me to
my interest in graphic design and so
from Virginia Beach i was in Virginia
Beach from kindergarten through twelfth
grade
my father was primarily computer systems
analyst and was also a stock broker for
a while and my mother did a variety of
odd jobs and she also made a lot of
things that she sold a lot of crafts you
know we had a garage full of jigsaws and
sanding belts and tools woodworking
tools and so I was always in an
environment of making things and
creating things and furthermore making
things for ourselves so a lot of my toys
growing up or homemade toys you know
cars made have chunks of wood with milk
carton lids four wheels and things like